Hôm nay, người thương đình ngà Mỹ tại Alaskan ngày 18,
từ 20 năm lớn, khi đây là lần đối thoại trực tiếp kéo dài nhất,
giữa tổng thong là đi nhipu chiến và bà tổng thống đưa nơi trăm.
Giù không đưa ra thả thòn cuộc thay,
cuộc gặp được phó chủ tịch khỏi đồng ăn linh ngà,
chủ mi trìm, mẹ phải đẹp đánh giá,
là mang lại nhiều cái quả đáng chui,
chứ khách là khó phục cơ trị gặp gỡ cấp cao Trung Hoà Bình,
và không càng theo cái điều kiện sáng buộc.
Ông mất phải đáp nhìn đình,
tổng thống của chiến đã nếu chưa tiếp tục điều kiện của Más Căva,
liên quan tối xung đồ đu khuyên à,
và trong bố cạnh đó thì tổng thống trăm được chó là đã lửa trọng
cách tiếp tận kiểm trai, chánh xa tăng áp lực lên ngà,
ích nhất từ xa đoạn hiện nay.
Tất nhiệm phân tích nhìn nhận hội nghỉ giúp Más Căva dùi chỉ không dành trường lượng.
Chúng khi Washington thử dẫn dự như chình trong phương tức tiếp tận với ngà,
bây tổng thống trong am chỉ sẽ hóa năm đặt thêm trường phà,
được xem là bức thay đổi lớn sau khi những chuyện bố trước đó,
điều này tạo ra xưa điện để hài bên cân nhắc những mức đi tiếp theo.
Đồng thời cho thấy nữ lượng dưới chiến thình đủ thoại
thay vì con thẳng lớp thang.